what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and today and yesterday we have gotten a
lot of news about the Fantastic Four
coming to the MCU now yesterday you
might have heard that we now have an
official date of when the Fantastic Four
film is going to begin filming and this
sparked a lot of debate on whether or
not the Fantastic Four had already been
cast and today director Matt shackman
has recently spoken up in a couple of
different interviews about what the
whole casting situation is right now
with the Fantastic Four he also talked
about whether or not he's heard all of
the Fantastic Four casting rumors and
what he thinks about them and you might
be kind of surprised with the responses
that he gives in both of these separate
interviews I've heard some people
already say that they're kind of
confused about what he said because he
kind of says two different things in
each interview but don't worry we're
going to break it all down for you so
you understand everything that's going
on so first thing that you need to know
about the Fantastic Four is that Matt
shackman is directing the film
originally it was going to be John Watts
the director of the Spider-Man
homecoming Trilogy however he decided to
take a break from directing superhero
films and I would definitely say that he
earned it after directing Spider-Man
homecoming far from home and of course
no way home then it was announced that
Mack shackman was going to direct in his
place now if you're not familiar with
Who Matt shackman is he directed One
Division so needless to say he's had
some success in the past many people
love One Division and consider it one of
the best if not the best Disney plus MCU
show out there so this is good news and
like I said recently he has opened up
doing interviews with many different
outlets now the first one we have to
talk about is his interview with the rap
where he talks about leaving the Star
Trek franchise to go back to Marvel to
direct A Fantastic Four in this
interview is where we find out that he
States the Fantastic Four reboot is
going to commence an early 2024. so here
it is a confirmation that the the
Fantastic Four movie is going to begin
filming in early 2024. now you obviously
cannot start filming unless you have
every character cast and usually you
have the cast well before you start
filming so of course the conversation
now is have the members of the Fantastic
Four in the rest of the movie including
the villain have they been cast already
so far we've heard a ton of rumors like
Galactus is going to be the main villain
the Silver Surfer should also be in the
movie but he should be coming in a
special presentation before the
Fantastic Four movie to get people ready
for Galactus to be the villain there's
also rumors that Dr Doom could be the
villain even if not the main villain he
could still make an appearance so
filming is about a year away and a lot
of people are stating well they have to
have the cast already however Matt
shackman has recently commented in two
different interviews about the casting
rumors and if they have already cast
them or not and like I said he actually
gives two different responses keep that
in mind as we talk about what he first
said in an interview with collider he is
asked about the fan Fantastic Four and
asked about the casting and here's what
he said all the casting stuff you see is
just rumors we are early in our process
there we have nothing to announce right
now and certainly when we do we'll let
you know so here Matt shackman says that
they are just rumors no one's been cast
yet however in another interview with
comicbook.com he has a different answer
and you can check out what he said here
in an interview with Chris Killian over
at comicbook.com Chris Killian asked him
if he's tired of the Fantastic Four
rumors that are going around and here's
what he said
there are a lot out there man yeah they
really are it's pretty amazing I'm gonna
look I I as I learned from Wanda
division two it is so lovely to see the
level of Engagement that fans have with
this material because I'm a fan too and
I have been reading Fantastic Four since
I was a kid I love these characters
um I love the chance that we have to
bring them to the MCU and I really want
to get it right and I know that
everybody out there is really excited
and feels passionate in the same way
wanting to get it right
um and so I encourage it I think it's
great
um but yeah I have no real answers for
anyone today about about casting sure
sure yeah I mean have they even been
cast we could put these rumors to bed
like just to bed right now
uh yeah okay I don't get anybody in
trouble
unfortunately no comments to make sorry
at the very least can you confirm that
Galactus is not going to be a cloud in
the MCU
I could either confirm nor to die
anything oh yeah all right all right I
respect that so as you can see here Matt
shackman has changed his answer which is
incredibly interesting he changed it
from no no one's been cast to no comment
so from a no to a basically I can't tell
you now as we know Kevin feige has his
sniper pointed at everyone involved in
any project that's going on at Marvel
Studios Kevin feige wants nothing
getting out about his projects and
Marvel security is real but what's
really cool about this interview with
comicbook.com is that he says he
actually enjoys the casting rumors and
he encourages them but when specifically
asked about whether or not the Fantastic
Four members have been cast he gave us a
no comment and like I mentioned of
course we have the rumors and the
reports from some insiders that Galactus
is going to be the main villain of the
Fantastic Four film and when asked if
Galactus was at least not going to be a
cloud he said no comment he could have
said something like I don't know if
Galactus is is ever going to come or
when he is going to come but hopefully
he's not going to be a cloud he didn't
say that he simply said no comment he
said I can neither confirm nor deny
anything now this sounds like to me that
he met with Kevin feige after maybe one
or two interviews and was like hey don't
say anything Kevin feige told him to not
even deny the claims that the Fantastic
Four have been cast already Kevin feige
does like the mystery because it does
keep the hype it keeps people talking
about it so he probably told Matt
shackman Hey listen don't say their cast
don't say they're not cast just say no
comment every time somebody asks about
something just say you can't say
anything that's typical Marvel Studios
101 don't say yes don't say no Marvel
likes to officially announce things
themselves but of course we typically
know beforehand thanks to some insiders
out there now what exactly does this
mean for the Fantastic Four have they
been cast already or not a lot of people
have been saying yes a lot of people
have been saying no and the biggest
thing right now is that people are
asking well how are you going to start
are filming the movie in early 2024 if
you don't have the cast well that's
still a year away so they don't have to
have cast already for it they still have
time and I don't think that they
actually have however I do think they
know who they want to play the cast
typically when Marvel Studios has cast
people to play certain members the
Insiders typically know and either
tweeted out or post it on their patreons
or websites or whatever it may be and
eventually word does get around that
Marvel Studios have come to a decision
and have officially cast someone or at
least are in the process of negotiating
contracts and sadly we haven't heard
anything about any contracts lately What
We Have Heard recently is that Dev Patel
could be playing Mr Fantastic in that
Marvel Studios might want a person of
color to play Reed Richards so Dev Patel
might be the closest that we have of
knowing who Mr Fantastic could be now
the other rumored ones are of course
John Krasinski Penn Badgley Adam Driver
and John David Washington and one that I
actually think I would enjoy is John Cho
I think that would be really interesting
and I think he could do it now as far as
who could play Sue's storm The Invisible
Woman of course we have John krasinski's
wife Emily Blunt Jody Comer a Benoist
Lily James Isaac Gonzalez and Natalia
Dyer these are the names who are most
talked about when the rumors about
casting for the Fantastic Four have been
going around so right now these are our
best choices but of course if we hear
anything from anyone we'll be sure to do
an update video keeping you all in the
know of what is happening with the
Fantastic Four casting so be sure to
subscribe and hit that notification Bell
so you don't miss out on any of the
latest videos don't forget to like the
video and leave a comment down below
letting us know your thoughts on who you
would like to play the cast of The
Fantastic Four don't forget to follow us
on Twitter and Instagram and as always
thank you all so much for watching woof
woof